In addition to specifically looking at conformity, social psychologists also
look at social factors that pressure us to act in certain ways. And here we're
talking about social norms. Now social norms are rules of acceptable behavior
that are imposed on us by our culture. And norms actually vary by culture. For
example, maybe you can think of a social norm that's specific to your culture.
For example, when I was younger, I was living and working in Tokyo. And I was
very unfamiliar with the Japanese culture. But there was one social norm that I
noticed right away, that was different from the way I grew up. And that was
that the Japanese kept their shoes outside their door. Perhaps you can think of
some social norms and talk about those on the forum. Now what I realized later
is that the Japanese kept their shoes outside of their house. Not only for
practical purpose, such as keeping the house clean, but also for spiritual
purposes. But now let's go back to Lauren and look a little bit more
specifically at conformity.